[Musique]
un conducteur d'un deux roues à moteur
dit la sagesse des nations est sur la
route un élément parfois dangereux mais
toujours sans défense c'est peut être
sujet à toutes les chutes ne se protéger
même pas la tête
la loi vient d'y mettre bon ordre
aujourd'hui le casque est obligatoire
mais est tout de même pas n'importe quel
casque pas celui ci dont l'appoint de
paratonnerre et peu convaincante
à celui ci non plus un peu trop
décoratifs pour l'époque que nous vivons
quant à ce dernier en dépit des
garanties qu'ils offrent
il semble quand même un peu dépassé non
le casque obligatoire est un casque
étudié uniquement pour les chocs à l'ap
est apte à protéger selon les normes les
plus protectrices la boîte crânienne de
son possesseur
à preuve les essais de résistance de
tout ordre imposé à ses coiffures auquel
tout médiocrité est absolument interdit
[Musique]
un casque établi en vue de la protection
doit absolument protéger reste que de
mauvais esprit parleront d'élégance
méconnu de dignité méprisés arrêtons les
du prince philippe à la reine
d'angleterre et au président de la
république que de nobles front n'ont pas
craint de porter ce qu'on peut à juste
titre a péri si un couvre chef
et puis quelle sécurité et même en
dehors des dangers de la route
est ce que le casque motocyclistes ne
deviendrait pas avec facilité tout
simplement la coiffure d'extérieur
[Musique]
et même d'intérieur